herzlich willkommen zum schön schlau
tutorial wie mache ich einen guten power
netz lucas burg hat uns in den
kommentaren gefragt bringen power tabs
etwas kleinkinder und großeltern halten
hier gerne mittagsschläfchen als
erwachsener schlägt man sich dann eher
mit kaffee durch den tag manch einer
schwört auf power netz zwischendrin
schnell auf dem schreibtisch andere
finden sich nach dem mittagsschlaf noch
müder als vorher
wie ist das bei euch und warum ist das
bei jedem anders es könnte daran liegen
wie lange ihr nett wenn wir einschlafen
durchlaufen wir vier schlafphasen phase
eins und zwei sind sogenannte live
schlagen
phase 3 und fiel tiefschlaf was kennt
ihr das ihr geld durch einen kurzen
mittagsschlaf ihr stellt den wecker auf
zehn minuten und wenn der wecker
klingelt habt ihr noch nicht eine
sekunde geschlafen ja ich wäre ja nicht
so sicher deren menschen die aus
schlafphase 1 oder 2 geweckt werden
glauben sehr oft dass sie noch nicht
geschlafen haben obwohl es gar nicht
stimmt und trotzdem ist dieser sehr
leichte schlaf oft schon ziemlich
erholsame knackpunkt für einen perfekten
powernap liegt also darin nicht über
diese leicht schlafphasen hinaus zu
schlagen wenn man nämlich erstmal in
eine tiefschlafphase abgedriftet ist und
daraus dann wieder aufstehen möchte dann
fühlt man sich nach dem netz noch müde
als faustregel alles unter 30 minuten
sollte die perfekten bauern im ausmachen
nachdem ihr wache konzentrierter und
produktiver sein solltet
wenn euer bürotisch für einen powernap
zu ungemütlich ist dann hilft auch nur
kaffee mehr dazu findet ihr hier trüben
vielen dank lukas wird eine frage wenn
ihr noch fragen habt dann schreibt sie
in die kommentare
ansonsten abonnieren nicht vergessen
dann sehen wir uns nämlich nächsten
donnerstag wieder